♪ BOOTY KINGS AND UNCLE BUTT ♪
WE'RE THE KINGS ♪
♪ LEG UP, LEG UP ♪
BOOTY KING'S IN THE BUILDING SO
THE GIRLS GONNA SHAKE ♪
SKIRTS SO TIGHT YOU WOULD THINK
SHE'S NAKED ♪
BOTTOMS UP ♪
I AIN'T TALKING ABOUT THE DRINK
MAN ♪
THE BOOTY'S SO COLD IT COULD
ESCAPE ELLA RAKE ♪
DOWN YOUR BACK I DRINK IT LIKE A
SNAPPLE ♪
IS IT ON THE MENU?
IS.
>> SORRY, WE'RE JUST HERE WITH
OUR FRIENDS.
>> COOL.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO RESPECT OUR
WISHES?
>> YEAH, TIME'S CHANGED.
♪ SHAKE YOUR BOOTY
WE LOVE TO TOUCH YOUR BOOTY BUT
WE RESPECT YOUR VOICE
CHOP IT LOW
IF YOU INSIST, WE TREAT THAT
BOOTY RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE ALLIES
IN THIS
♪ I'M ON A MISSION ♪
GOING STRAIGHT FOR MY WHISKEY
I ROLL DOWN MY WINDOW AND I
DON'T SAY
BECAUSE I'M GROWING AND I KNOW
MY PENIS WON'T BE SHOWING ♪
WHAT DO YOU DO ♪
♪ I SHOULDN'T SAY HOES --
>> CAN'T CALL PEOPLE PITCHES NO
MORE?
>> WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO CALL
THEM THEN?
>> NAGS.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT, MAN.
>> WE NEED THAT PUSHBACK IN OUR
LIVES.
>> NEED THAT PUSHBACK.
♪ ELABORATE UNCLE BUTT
YEAH UNCLE BUTT TAKING CRAP ♪
TAKE THE GRILLE OUT ♪
♪ BOOTY FUTURE ♪
♪ I APPRECIATE YOUR FACE
LIKE A TRAP ♪
♪ HIGH RESPECT ♪
♪ THE HIGH CONCEPT LIKE A BOUNTY
♪
♪ HINDUS LOVE BOOTY ♪
♪ ONCE YOU BRING ME BOTH, YOU
KNOW YOU MAKE A MOVIE ♪
♪ YOU KNOW YOU'RE A VIXEN ♪
♪ ASK THE GIRL FOR HER
PERMISSION ♪
♪ IF YOU WISH ♪
♪ WE WILL PROTECT THAT BOOTY
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL LIES IN THIS
MISH
♪ BEFORE WE GET EMOTIONAL I'M
PUTTING ON PROTECTION ♪
♪ RESPECT IS THE GAME AND BOOTY
IS THE SCRIMMAGE ♪
AND I PLAY GOOD DEFENSE IF THAT
BOOTY GET OFFENDED ♪
♪ NEVER GET AGGRESSIVE ♪
THAT BOOTY GOT INSURANCE ♪
IS THAT BOOTY GOT PROGRESSIVE ♪
♪ ALL THAT BOOTY GOT YOU LOOKING
LIKE A HUNCHBACK ♪
♪ RESPECT LADY SO I TREAT YOU
LIKE AN EQUAL ♪
♪ I STARE AT THAT BOOTY LIKE AN
EQUAL ♪
♪ TREAT THAT BOOTY ON THE FLOOR
♪
♪ THE RIGHT FOR THE BOOTY ♪
♪ I NEED PERMISSION FIRST ♪
♪ PERMISSION
♪ TAKE THAT OUT OF YOUR MOUTH
OPEN BUT ♪
♪ OH, MY BAD
♪
>> WHERE ARE THE HOES AT?
[ BLEEP ]
YOU NEED REAL TEETH FIRST ♪
♪ I'M ON A MISSION BUT AFTER
THAT FIRST I NEED PERMISSION ♪